DR. SHARAD JONES: Hey, everyone.
Welcome back.
Today's video, we're going to
be covering identity and access
management.
So the idea here is, really
throughout this process,
we're going to have users--
you guys are users
on our AWS account.
And so we have this
standing open question of,
how do we manage access?
Should we manage access?
What are the benefits?
Why would we, why
wouldn't we manage access
to certain resources?
And you can imagine, obviously,
this scales up pretty
aggressively as you get
to larger companies.
There's always a security
risk with any sort of access
to a resource, to a tool.
And so we want to now
address the tools that
are available to us as in this
since we're the cloud admins,
we're the administrators of how
do we decide who accesses what
and when.
So we're going to
go through that,
the tools available for
this, we'll walk through it,
we'll see how those tools
look in action as well too.
The good thing is
though, again, this
is something you can play with.
This is available
for free on AWS.
So if you set up your own
AWS account or organization,
you have access or controls over
identity and access management
for free, you can create users,
delete users, change passwords,
all that stuff.
So it's your choice.
You can explore and we will
explore in this course.
So let me throw this
up full screen now,
and then I'll shrink myself
out of the way as usual.
And we'll go to the
bottom left hand corner
to be a little better.
Perfect.
Large enough that you can
see me, not too large to them
in the way.
That's the rule.
Perfect.
So let's start with some
motivating questions.
So let's imagine now you're,
again, this cloud admin.
You're handling the IT
services for a small company.
Maybe you only
have 50 employees,
and there's roughly 10 different
job titles or job categories.
And those are going to have
different seniority levels.
So some are going
to be more senior,
some director level, some
might be entry level juniors,
interns, all that stuff.
So the question is
then, how would you
handle controlling access
to cloud resources?
And maybe we'll do this one
as a discussion board too,
but we'll see.
It might be-- the answer
might be clear afterwards,
so I'll about it some.
But either way, how
would you handle that?
Maybe pause and think
about it for a second.
Could you maybe say, if
we just give everybody
appropriate training
on cloud security,
could we just limit
the complexity of this
and just give
everyone full access?
And I think that's probably
a leading question.
We typically don't want to
give everybody full access
to everything, otherwise
you guys would probably
have full access right now.
And so what can we
do to mitigate that,
limit the need to give
everybody full access?
And so AWS's identity and
access management-- and again,
this is--
you'll actually see IAM tools
in Google Cloud, Azure as well.
This is not unique to AWS.
This is just the platform
we're using today.
But this is a critical
component of any cloud platform,
and it's used to
manage and acce--
manage access to the resources
on that cloud platform.
And there's three questions
that are answered at all times.
Who can access the resource,
which resource can be accessed,
and what can the user
do to the resource,
and then how can those
resources be accessed?
Which may be some of
those seem redundant,
but we'll clarify why those
are three distinct questions.
And when I say resource,
again, there's a note there,
I mean, these kind
of tools and entities
that you can use
within an AWS account.
EC2 instances, S3 buckets,
but also then some
of the more advanced tools.
There's going to be Amazon
Transcribe, and AWS deep lens,
and all these other things that
you could do in there that cost
money usually.
And how can we limit
the access to those?
Or those things are going to
be referred to as resources,
and that's what we're
trying to determine
how to limit the access to.
So there's four
central components
of an AWS resource
or of IAM components.
So I'm going to shrink
myself really, really small
now so I'm not
covering anything.
But there's the user,
group, policy, and the role.
So at the user level is
probably the easiest.
That's just a person
or interestingly,
it can also be an application
that can authenticate
with an AWS account.
So what I mean by could
be an application,
it could be that you
give your EC2 instance.
Your EC2 instance could
conceivably be itself a user.
It's going to have--
you can grant your EC2
instance specific access
to certain resources.
You might want to do this right
in that some EC2 instances might
need access to maybe
a private S3 bucket.
And so in that
sense, you don't want
to give-- just say,
well, because Sally's
the user of that
EC2 instance, I'm
just going to give Sally access
to all S3 accounts or S3 buckets
because she's a great data
scientist and we can trust her.
Well, you might want
to be that, well, Sally
needs to determine what exactly
she needs for the exact EC2
instance she's using.
Because again, there's
always the risk
that somebody gets
access to the account,
somebody gets access
to her secret key,
and now can log in and
potentially acquire
sensitive information.
And so that's the idea
behind giving an application
separate or separate access.
And so that's why
we say a user can
be a person or an application.
The IAM group is then just going
to be a collection of IAM users.
The reason we do
this is-- sorry,
my hair is like
flicking in my face.
Silly.
The reason we do
this is, it allows
us to simplify the process of
granting access to IAM users.
So if we say, OK, well, maybe
all the interns at our company
are kind of working
on the same task.
Rather than having
to manage individual,
OK, you're getting
the access to this,
you're getting access to this,
I'm just going to
put them in a group.
So that whenever I need to
give them access to more stuff,
I can make a blanket change.
And it might seem familiar
because this is exactly what I'm
doing for this course.
Is that you guys
are all IAM users.
That's how you
got access, that's
how you got logged into AWS.
You're all part of an IAM group
that is going to be this data
or IS 3600 course.
That's the course that
we're in right now.
And as you progress through the
course, as the weeks progress,
I'm going to give you
guys the access necessary
to different tools
and resources.
And so that way, I can
quickly and efficiently
make sure that everybody
has the same access level.
And I also don't have to
worry that, well, if I just
grant you guys blanket access to
everything, that maybe as you're
learning, you make a mistake,
you leave a big instance EC2
instance up and running and
cost us a bunch of money.
And then all of a sudden,
people come complaining to me.
So that's the idea, and that's
why bucket you guys into an IAM
group as well too.
So then the IAM policy
is the actual document
that defines what
those resources are
that you can access
and the level at which
you can access those resources.
Because there's going
to be certain things of,
like, again S3 is
a perfect example.
I might want to allow you
to read from an S3 bucket,
I'm fine with you downloading
data from that S3 bucket,
but I don't want you to have
access to write to that.
Because writing to
that is what it's
going to cost us,
because now you're
all of a sudden adding
more resources there.
So it's more per
gigabyte storage costs.
And so that's what
I want to limit,
is actually your write access.
And so I'll give
you a read access,
but I won't give
you write access.
And so that's what we mean by
determining the level of access
to each of those resources.
And then finally, the IAM role.
This is just a
mechanism, a tool to use
to grant permissions for
making specific requests to AWS
services.
So again, for
example, this could
be something where I say, I
assign to my EC2 instance,
an IAM role, that is the
role of maybe EC2 admin.
Maybe I'm fine with
this EC2 instance having
the role of being able to
spin up a new EC2 instances
or shut down EC2 instances
because maybe I have written
some application in
this instance that
is designed to automatically
monitor the company's
EC2 instances.
And so I need it to be able to
spin up and shut down other EC2
instances.
And so therefore, I will assign
to it the IAM role of EC2 admin.
That's what we mean by this.
It's a lot of words.
I'm using a lot
of similar words,
so I'm sure it's
probably overlapping.
We're going to see
this in practice
again too, so don't worry if
it's not all clicking yet.
The whole thing about here
is experiential learning.
We want to make sure we
actually work with these tools
and see how they
work in practice.
So then there's
two different ways
that we are going
to grant access
to IAM users, programmatic
and management console.
So what you guys have been
using today or up to today
is almost exclusively been
the AWS management console.
I don't think we've
done anything yet
where we've actually touched
or used programmatic access.
But that's kind of the more--
I don't want to say
the more common way,
but the more practical way to
use it in most day to day tasks.
What the programmatic access
is it's basically saying,
well, I'm going to
assign you an access
key ID and a secret access key
or some sort of application,
an access key ID and
a secret access key,
and it's going to use that to
make calls via the AWS Command
Line Interface, that's
what CLI stands for,
or the software development kit.
And so it can go
through those platforms
from a programmatic standpoint,
either like in your Python code
or directly on the
command line to do things
like create buckets,
spin up EC2 instances,
launch resources, kick
off lambda events.
All that stuff can be
done programmatically.
So basically,
anything you can do
when you're clicking through
the menus in AWS, basically,
all of that can be done from
the command line as well too.
And I hope you can see
why that's important
because again, I can automate
things on the command line.
It's not really easy to
automate clicking through menus.
That is really hard to do,
and it's not very robust.
Because if they change
where something's
positioned on the console
menu, then I might actually--
my program will break.
So more often than not, we want
to use programmatic access such
that the process
to change something
or to do some tasks to
spin up some resource
can be or can be automated and
can stay the same no matter
what happens on the back end.
And so by default, IAM
users don't have access
to really anything.
The best practice here, and I've
even said it a few times now,
is to follow this principle
of least privilege.
So basically, to
access something,
you need to be granted
the access to it.
By default, you have
access to nothing.
The reason we do this,
it's a little bit
annoying from
management standpoint
because then you're obligated
to constantly grant access,
grant access, grant access.
But from a security
perspective, it's
way, way better
because there's not
some sort of account that's
just looming out there
that shouldn't be
accessing something.
It could even be something where
maybe you work for a company,
and after somebody
gets fired or let go,
they should lose access
to their account.
But for whatever reason, it
doesn't instantly knock it down.
Well, we want to make
sure that they only
have the least
privilege, the least
access necessary
for their tasks such
that they can't all of a
sudden do some other damage.
We can at least
monitor or we know
that they'd be constrained to
some region of AWS resources.
And so that's this idea of
principles of least privilege.
So you can see here the
IAM user group or role will
be granted full access
to EC2 instances,
but then could be granted read
only access to the S3 bucket.
If it needed write
access, we would then
have to explicitly
grant it, write access.
And so the idea again
being that everything
is very, very explicit.
If it's not explicitly
stated, it doesn't happen.
We do this via the IAM
policies we talked about,
and the IAM policy, as we
said, is just a document.
It's a JSON, JavaScript Object
Notation, we'll see this a lot,
whether in this course or just
kind of throughout your time
in working in the tech
world, JSON documents
are fairly common.
And it's just
something that's going
to list the permissions in a
nice almost dictionary format
of the permissions that
allow or deny access
to the very specific resources.
There's two types of policies.
And again, I apologize that
it's a lot of just things.
The idea is not for
you to memorize this.
So if you don't feel like you
are picking it all up right now
or you don't remember these
things, that's perfectly OK.
My goal is to introduce
them, and so that you
know have these as a resource.
You can come back
to this video, you
can come back to these
slides and figure out
the exact specific thing you
need for your task at hand.
But it's not to
memorize everything.
So don't stress on that.
We're never going
to test you and say,
what are the
characteristics of identity
based policy What's the
characteristic of resource based
policy?
But if you do take the AWS
Cloud Practitioner exam,
you will be expected to know
these things and the differences
between resource based policy
and identity based policy.
And so that's why we want
to give you these resources
so you can study them if that's
something you'd like to do.
But getting back to it, we
have two types of policies.
And remember, these are those
JSON documents that explicitly
allow or deny access.
The identity based policy is
attached to an IAM entity.
It will be attached to a user,
a group or a role, right.
These policies will specify
what can be performed
and what can't be performed.
Remember that the least
privileged process
or the principle
of least privilege
states that you won't
have access to anything
unless explicitly granted.
But you can also explicitly
deny as well too so that there's
no worry or there's no chance
that they could maybe get access
through some other means.
It's going to
explicitly deny it.
So that is an option
as well, though again,
it's almost a redundant
step in most cases.
You can attach a single
policy to multiple entities
as well too, and that's
often very common.
So it might be that I assign
or I create an IAM policy that
is for data 3600 level access,
and I assign that to a role.
Well, that role may get
assigned to some individuals
or maybe I'll have
a TA that needs
to play around with
some things and see
how it works from
their perspective,
and so I assign them that role
temporarily so they can play
around with it, see what it's
like, from your environment,
and then they can be assigned
a different role that
would change their access
to level access or something
like that.
And then I can also take that
IAM policy, that identity based
policy, and assign it to
the user group as well too.
That is going to be you
guys here at the data 3600
class or the IS 3600 class.
Sorry, I get the
prefixes mixed up.
And also, a single entity
can have multiple policies.
So you could be assigned the
data 30 or the IS 3600 policy,
but you could also
be assigned-- maybe
you're working on an ASC
project for the Department.
And so you could also
be assigned-- well,
I'm going to give you a
little bit of extra access
that is for a project we're
working on that needs access
to specific S3 buckets.
So you'll get the policy
for project 10 ASC project.
And the idea here
is that, again,
the reason we want
to allow that--
and also this is why we have
explicit deny statements too
in policies, is that maybe
in the IS 3600 class,
I give you a blanket, you don't
have access to S3 right now.
Maybe it's early on, so I
don't want you accessing S3.
Well, then it might be
that for this project,
you need access to a
specific S3 bucket.
If I have an explicit blanket
deny on all S3 buckets,
that will supersede access to
anything-- any other specific S3
buckets.
So if I said, IS 3600
students can access S3
and then I also give you a new
policy that has specific S3
access, this one of an
explicit deny of S3 buckets
will supersede that.
But if I don't explicitly
deny S3 access,
then it's just assumed
that you are denied access.
But if then in another
policy, I grant
you access to a
specific S3 bucket,
you'll get access to that
one but not have access
to any of the other ones.
So that's subtle.
But the idea is, again, I'm
going to explicitly deny what
cannot be superseded at
all, but if it's implicit.
I don't want you to get there,
but if there's a specific use
case, then I can give it to you,
then I don't explicitly deny.
There's also a
resource-based policies
that are attached
obviously to a resource.
So an S3 bucket,
an EC2 instance,
whatever you want to call,
pick your favorite resource,
and that's going to specify
who has access to the resource
and what can be performed on it.
So again, it's applied
to the whole resource.
So you could say, I'm only
going to allow S3 Glacier Deep
Archive to be read
from, because maybe that
is where I'm putting my
company's secure and long term
backup storage or backup
copies, and I don't
need that be deleted ever.
Worst case, we'll
just write new stuff
and we'll just keep
the old stuff in there,
but I never want to let
you delete from that.
And so I can make it a very
explicit blanket resource-based
policy that says, nobody
can delete from this.
The only way you could ever
delete something from that
is for an admin user
that has admin privileges
to go in, remove that
policy, and then go in
and explicitly delete that.
And so the idea here again
being that it's very intentional
steps.
Those very intentional
steps and explicit steps
are what separates
the security here.
So an example of an IAM policy.
So this is what one
would look-- this is what
a JSON document looks like.
So you can read it like this.
So you see these curly
brackets, this one is open,
this one down here is closed.
So that's going to contain
the whole JSON note--
JSON document
information in there.
So it's a dictionary-- very
similar to a dictionary
in Python.
And then you'll see here
that we have-- oops.
We have version,
and so that's going
to specify again the version
that we're working on.
The statement though is
what actually contains
the explicit allow or deny.
So you see in here,
this statement says,
I want to have the effect
of allowing DynamoDB S3
access and these
specific S3 buckets
and this explicit
DynamoDB table name.
It's not blanket.
It's only an allow for these
actions on these resources.
So you see that effect
action resource trio there.
And then within that statement,
that's the square bracket here.
You see that's the
square brackets, a list.
It is a list.
Within that, there's
another statement
or, yeah, another
statement, another effect,
and that's a deny effect.
And that effect denies
access to DynamoDB and S3,
and then it's going to have
but excluding these resources.
So you see there, it's
not resources excluding.
I don't really care
about you guys knowing
exactly the syntax of this.
I just want to show you
roughly how it works.
But see here that
in explicit deny
statement will take precedence
over an allow statement.
So if I deny it--
if I allowed it and then
I explicitly deny it,
that will take precedence.
So like I was saying is if
you're working on the IS 3600
or working under that policy and
it has an explicit deny of S3,
I don't care if I have
anything else that
comes in there that says, you
should be granted S3 access,
even if it's, you should
be granted S3 admin access.
There's still an
explicit deny in there
that will always
take precedence.
So again, just to
show this explicitly
in a flow chart, the way AWS
is reading this on the backend
is it says, if you try to do
something, it's going to say,
first off, is this
permission explicitly denied?
If it's a yes, it doesn't matter
what else happens after that,
you are denied
access to blanket.
If it's not explicitly
denied, it then it
will be asking, OK, well,
is it explicitly allowed?
If it is, then great,
you can access it.
If it's not, you
are still denied.
So you see, it's
more often than not,
you're going to end up
in the deny statement.
It has to be both not
explicitly denied and then
explicitly allowed to allow
you access to the resource.
And so as we talked
about IAM groups,
it's just a nice way
to aggregate people
under one bucket.
And so I can just assign
a policy to the group,
and that policy
trickles down then
to all the users
within that group.
So here's an example of maybe
I have admins, developers,
and testers.
And so these people,
all I have to do
is change the policy
the resource access
from the whole group level.
And each of these individuals
will be given access as well to.
A user can belong to
multiple groups though.
Though remember, that
explicit allow, deny
can come into play here.
So if you ever have somebody
assigned to multiple groups
and something's not
working the way you expect,
look at those explicit
denies and see
if maybe they're
superseding something
that you don't want them
to and then rethink how you
need to structure that policy.
There's no default group though.
So there's not like you can
say, everybody in this--
that's in this
organization can do this
without explicitly adding
everybody to that organization
or adding a policy to a resource
within that whole organization,
there's no default group
that you can assign things to
and you can't nest
the groups either.
So I can't be--
all developers or admins and
all testers or developers
or something like that.
It has to be separate entities.
We really want to avoid
any sort of ambiguity
of what sort of permission
should or shouldn't
be allowed anywhere.
And then the IAM roles,
that's an identity
with specific
permissions added to it.
So again, the way you want
to think about this is,
maybe there are certain
things where I don't--
again, so it's similar to a user
that you attach policies to it.
But you don't want to uniquely
associate that policy with just
one user, and you
don't necessarily
want to create a group
for all these users.
You're just saying
that, hey, there's
this task that could
happen, and the access that
would be needed to do
this task, I can just
define it by that role.
And then whether it's a
person, application or service,
I can assign that role
to them and they'll
have that relevant access.
So it allows you
to streamline this.
So if there's common tasks
that need to be done,
maybe it's that
there's a user that
is working through a
automatic setup or some code
on the back end that
needs to be run repeatedly
and they're testing it
out on their platform
or their local environment or
in the cloud on an EC2 instance,
I can assign the role
to that EC2 instance.
And then I can say,
OK, if this role is
all they need to
complete that task,
I can now assign that
IAM role to a service.
I can attach it to
some container service
so that all the containers spun
up have this IAM role attached
and they all have the
same access that developer
had for that task.
So it's just to try to
simplify some of these things.
So I give some examples here.
Granting an IAM user access
to larger EC2 instances
for a specific project.
So again, maybe you're working
on an ASC project for us,
and we all of a sudden
need to use a really
beefy computer or a GPU.
Well, rather than
having to go in there
and manually change what
your user can access
and then go back and remove
what you can access and change
some things, I can
just quickly say, well,
here's the IAM
role for GPU access
for data science research.
And once you're done with that
task, I can repeal that role,
and then you don't
have access anymore.
So it simplifies again.
And I can do that for a
bunch of people really quick,
and then remove those
and all that good stuff.
You can use it for
granting an application
access to specific resources,
and this is really useful.
And you'll see this later on
to avoid embedding credentials
in the app.
So let's say that you need to--
in this specific
application, you
need to query some sort of
table, some sort of big database
that you have.
And rather than having
to explicitly put,
well, this is the user
ID and a passkey that
will let you access
that database,
rather than putting
that into the app,
I can just assign
the role or yeah,
the role to that application.
And so then I don't
have this risk
that, well, if
somebody gets access
to the source code
of my app, I don't
have my password and username
embedded in there somewhere.
That's the idea and help
that security out some.
And then yeah, granting access
to resources in your account
or to a user in a
different account.
So it's just that granting.
That's kind of a
blanket statement.
So here's an example
use of an IAM role.
So let's say, again,
you have an application
that runs on an EC2
instance, but needs access
to an S3 bucket.
So the application
is running here.
This rectangle is
representing the EC2 instance.
Well, I can define
an IAM policy that
grants access to a
specific bucket, the photos
bucket within S3.
I can attach that policy to a
role, and I can assume that role
or have that EC2 instance
assume that role such
that it has permission
to access that S3 bucket.
So see, that's the flow.
Attach a policy to a role, have
an instance assume that role,
and then it has that access.
And in the event
that I don't need
it-- don't want it to
have access anymore,
I can repeal that role.
I can pull that role
from them, but I
don't have to necessarily pull
policies and change policies
around or anything like that.
It really simplifies
the amount of coding
I have to do because
then I don't have
to write a bunch of
JSON over and over
that denies and allows
all over the place.
And that's going to get
messy and you're going
to probably mess something up.
And then there's also
the account root user.
You won't see in this course
unless you create your own AWS
account entirely.
None of you will have
root user access.
There's only going to be one
root user that exists usually,
and it's also not
recommended to use that.
The root user has
access to everything.
That user can do anything they
want to do on the account.
They can set up any resources.
The thing is, they can also
assign any policies, roles,
repeal anything.
So access to that
root user account
is absolutely critical
to keep secure.
And so the real
way you do this is
even if you are the main
admin at your company,
you're the only person who
knows anything about AWS,
you'll set up the user--
you'll set up the AWS account,
you'll be granted root access.
But then the second
you get in there,
the first thing you
should do is just
go create an IAM
role for yourself
or an IAM user for yourself,
and you can grant them
a lot of permissions.
You could grant them
admin permissions
to mostly everything,
but it's still
going to be all controlled
through that user account
and only that user account
will be the one you use.
Keep that root
account to the side.
You really want to--
like I suggested here, disable
remove your account root user
access keys.
You really don't want to
be accessing from that
unless absolutely necessary.
It is the biggest
security hole in this.
And that's the
nature of security.
Is, it's hard to have--
actually, it's impossible to
have a perfect security system.
What we try to do
is mitigate risks.
And the root user is
the way we do this.
Is, we put everything into IAM
users and roles and policies
and groups, and
know that there is
one super user above all that
can technically allow access
to everything.
But that means we
just need to protect
that one user account
and everything else
is controlled separately.
That's the hope with this.
So keep that in mind.
Again, we won't do it
explicitly in this course
because you won't be asked to
do that, but that is the risk.
And so great.
I'll pause it there
now, and then we're
going to switch over
to a short demo on how
to add users and change
policies, that kind of stuff.
So we'll do that here in a
second once I switch my screens.
All right.
So picking up now from the
AWS management console,
let's zoom in again so you can
see something on the screen.
And now we just want to
explore some of the tools,
again, available in the
identity and access management,
as well as how do we
add people to groups
and all that good stuff?
And so I'll start by
just selecting IAM
or, again, you could search IAM.
And come over here.
And then under
Users, I've created--
all of you will be in
there, but I've also
created three test users,
user-1, user-2 and user-3.
So you can imagine these
are like new employees
that we have basically.
So let's click
User-1 for a second.
And I'll Zoom in even
more a little bit bigger.
So under User-1 now,
this is the summary page
for that individual.
So this is the Permissions page.
And as you see right now,
there are no permissions.
That's exactly by default.
When I created this account,
I didn't explicitly give them
any permissions at the start.
And so therefore, they have
no permission to do anything.
If you logged into this account,
you'd see the resources there,
but you couldn't
click on anything.
When you clicked
on everything, it
would be like no access
allowed or something like that.
You might have even
seen this already.
It's a banner-- that red banner
that comes across the top that
doesn't allow you access to it.
You can choose the
Groups tab here.
And if they were a part of a
group, they would see that here.
But this person, again,
is not part of a group.
We can look at the
security credentials.
And so they've been
assigned a console password,
but they haven't signed
in at all before.
And so because of that,
they won't be able to access
or they won't have changed
their password yet.
So they would need
to, again, log in,
create their new password
like you guys have
to do for the first time, and
then they could actually go
ahead and proceed through this.
We can also actually
manage this and require
that they have some sort of
multi-factor authentication,
whether it be through virtual
like an app on your phone
or a security key or
some other hardware
token that they use for
factor authentication.
So you can control
all of that here.
In the left hand side, we can
select User Groups though,
and this will pull
up all the user
groups we have in this account.
So you can see here,
we've got a couple there.
But for the most part,
I'm going to play
with these three or these are
three new ones I've created--
EC2 support, EC2 admin,
and then S3 support.
So let's click into the
EC2 support for a second.
And then this is the summary
page for that EC2 support group.
So you can see here,
again, what we have.
There's no users in this
group yet, so it's blank here.
But we can click
the Permissions tab
and see what permissions
they have access to.
And you see right now, I've
assigned a single policy
to that user group.
So this right here is a policy,
hence the policy name there,
and that's an Amazon
EC2 read only access.
This is actually a prebuilt
policy that's available on AWS.
It's built by AWS,
and so you don't
have to go through and
manually write these.
There's tons of these
default policies.
You can probably actually
see if we start typing--
I would have to do
under Add Permissions.
But either way, there's a ton
of these that you can choose,
and EC2 read only
access is one of them.
Because unsurprisingly,
sometimes you only
need to be able to
read from EC2 access.
And so I'll click
on that-- actually,
I'll go back for a second.
I just want to click
the little plus sign.
I don't want to read
the whole thing.
So if you click the
little plus sign,
you can actually
see a quick overview
of what the policy looks like,
the actual JSON underneath this.
And so the policy is
granting permissions
to basically list and describe
EC2 load balance, elastic load
balancing, CloudWatch,
and autoscaling.
But it's not going
to be able to modify
them or anything like that.
So think about it.
If you had like a support team
and their job was to figure out,
hey, is there any
EC2 instances that
are down or running
into issues, this policy
would allow them to do that.
It allows them to list
out all the EC2 instances
that are running or that
exist and then describe them
as well to provide
information about them.
But they can't launch
them, create new ones,
delete them or terminate
them, stop them,
or anything like that.
It's just read only access.
And so the basic structure
of this policy-- again,
we talked about
this a little bit,
but it's three
components-- an effect,
an action, and a resource.
You'll see everything
is in effect,
an action, and a resource.
The effect is either
allow or deny.
Do I allow this permission?
Do I explicitly deny it?
Explicit allow, explicit deny.
The action specifies
the API calls that can
be made against an AWS service.
If you guys aren't familiar
with APIs, it's OK.
It's application
programming interface.
This is what we're talking
about, that programmatic access.
I could go on the command
line and make a request
and say, hey, I want
to call EC2 describe,
describe all of
the EC2 instances
or list all the EC2 instances.
That's a call I'm making, a
request I'm making to AWS,
and then it's returning me
some sort of information.
And so the action specifies the
API calls that are allowed here.
So you see all of these
different ones that
are explicitly allowed are
API calls that they can do.
And the resource then
defines the scope
of entities covered
by that policy.
So for example--
[DOG BARKING]
Sorry.
OK.
Sorry about that.
My dog, that you guys have
now seen in pictures enough,
the doorbell rang, and
you can imagine that he
lost his mind almost instantly.
So brief hiccup.
But joys of online
lecturing, right?
But yeah.
So either way, as I was
saying, the resource aspect
of this, that's going to define
the scope of the entities
covered by the policy.
So you could put here a specific
S3 bucket or a specific EC2
instance, or you can just put
this asterisk, which just means
any resource within this scope.
So here we said,
allow EC2 describe,
so that means we can
discard any EC2 instance.
And again, we said the resource
could be any EC2 instance.
We didn't say only
EC2 instances within
or the sets of EC2 instance.
We want to be able to
describe all of them.
But you could specify here.
All right.
And then we can minimize
that again for a second.
Then let's jump over to--
or sorry, let's
see, user groups.
Yeah, I wanted to look
at the S3 support group.
So let's go back to the
user groups for a second.
Let's open up the
S3 support group,
and then we'll pull up this one.
So you see this one now--
oops, just under Permissions,
it doesn't have any users,
but it does have a policy.
And this one has S3
read only access.
And you'll notice though
that this is actually--
so where am I at here?
I'm sorry.
I'm getting mixed
up on my notes.
Oh, yeah.
So this is just telling
you-- showing you guys
that again, this is S3 access.
So again, we're allowing S3--
we're allowing this
access to Git S3 buckets,
list them, get lambda
object, list lambda objects.
And again, that applies
to all the resources.
But then if we go back now to--
this is what I was thinking.
I was jumping ahead of myself.
If we jump to EC2 admin group,
this one's a bit different.
So no users yet.
But under Permissions, you'll
see that this is actually
a customer inline policy.
And I'll go back so you
can see what I mean.
If I look at EC2 support
or S3 is the same one,
this EC2 read only access,
that's an AWS managed policy.
Again, that was one that
was designed already by AWS.
But under EC2 admin, I
created a new one inline,
so just for this one.
It's basically like clicking
Add Policy here to do that.
And so it says customer
inline, and it's
called EC2 describe
start stop instances.
So if we click that
one, maximize that,
we can see now that this policy
grants permission to view
or so it's got the describe
instances that the EC2
support had as well too,
but it also is allowed now
to start and stop instances.
So you see the effect
is allow, the action
is start and stop instances.
And we can, again, specify
the resources for it here.
Perfect.
So that is, again, a
bunch of user groups.
So we have three user
groups and three users.
So now let's imagine that
we're basically at a company,
and we recently hired user-1.
So let's pull up
our users again.
Go to users, and
we'll pull up user-1.
So we just recently
hired on user-1,
and they're going to be
providing support for S3--
for our S3 services.
So we're going to add them
to the S3 support group.
So the way to do this is to
jump over to the User Groups
category, select our
S3 support group,
and then under the Users
tab here, which we are,
we're going to click Add Users.
And then we're just going
to search for user-1,
we're going to
select them, and then
we're just going to add them.
So now, you see,
user-1's in that group.
Nothing too crazy here.
A lot of management is
clicking through menus,
so it's nice and easy to do.
Sorry, I think my
dog is barking again
at somebody else out front now.
It's just the mailman.
We're good.
Then the next step here is to
add user-2 we also hired on
to the EC2 support group.
So go user-2, EC2 support.
We'll go Add User, we'll
click them, add them there.
So now that has a user.
And then finally,
unsurprisingly, user-3
is going to be our EC2 admin.
Let's go here, Add Users,
and we'll go to user-3
and add it on.
Perfect.
And so now we have the admin,
our support, and our EC2 support
and our S3 support
staff loaded into there.
And so we can now
jump over and sign
in to our actual test users.
So I'm going to log in as if
I am, let's say, user-1 Oops.
User-1.
So again, they haven't
logged in before,
so I'll have to recreate or
create a new password for them.
Don't worry, I'll help
delete this by the time
you guys get to it.
So let's go-- so first,
I'm going to log out.
So we're to sign out here.
Or actually, I can
leave myself logged in.
I found this trick
actually before
that I could use where I
just use incognito window.
So I'm going to log
back into my account
so we can see what
they're doing 54826.
Perfect.
So then we're going to
jump over here, and let's
now launch an incognito window.
I'll just do it a
smaller window size here.
We can actually
split our screen.
Let's do that.
And I'll leave this split like
that so we see on both sides.
And so let's log
into those accounts.
So let's first go to
aws.amazon.com like usual.
Not create account.
We're going to just
sign into an account.
And now you'll see here
that we're an IAM user.
So the account alias
is the USU-ASC.
It's the one you guys are using.
And I made a note here of
the user's name and password,
the default password
I gave them.
So let's hope this works.
It's been a couple of weeks
since I set these accounts up.
Perfect.
All right.
Awesome so we can
close out that.
Cool.
Done.
We're good to go.
So awesome.
So now they're able to
log in and good to go.
All right.
That's what I forgot.
I gave them specific
passwords so
that I didn't have to do
the change in the password.
So that's why I
didn't do that step.
I forgot I had thought about
that annoyance in there.
So perfect.
So now we are logged
into user-1's account.
And we can see--
so let's go over here
in the Services menu,
and we'll do S3, open that up.
And so our user here,
I think we put him
into the S3 support group.
And so they have permission
to view these S3 buckets.
So we'll choose the name of--
so let's just take this.
Yeah, because we
already did this one.
Yeah.
So you can see here that they
can see all this information
in here because they
have access, again,
to list all the content.
Now let's actually see though
if they have access to EC2.
They shouldn't have access to
this if we did everything right.
So yeah, you see this API
error that is getting thrown
everywhere, you might have
already seen some of this if you
haven't-- if you don't have or
if you're not to the point where
you have access to this yet.
But you see you're
not authorized
to form this operation.
So they don't have EC2 access.
They can't list
these instances out.
So let's actually
sign out now and then
go into user-2's account.
So sign out.
Log back in.
USU-ASC, user-2.
Put in their password.
And so now if we go
into EC2, we should
be able to see everything.
Yep.
So we can see we don't have any
instances running right now.
There are a bunch of terminated
instances or stopped instances.
But you can see that
they have access
to read and click in
and describe and see all
this information about them.
But if we go now to
S3, they shouldn't
be able to see anything.
Yep.
So you see don't have
permission to list the buckets.
And also, under EC2 actually, if
we go here to Launch Instance,
I don't think it
should allow them too.
So let's just say, test user-2.
I'll leave everything
default. It's all good.
Key pair name.
And you'll see
instance launch failed.
So you're not
authorized to form this
because we haven't given
them permission to do that.
So all that stuff
is checking out.
Sorry, I realize I
left this screen small.
Hopefully, you guys
could see that.
OK.
Then finally, we will
jump over to user-3,
who they should have more
access because we gave them
admin access.
Let's sign out.
Let me sign into the console.
Same thing.
This is user-3.
And type in their password.
And now if we go to EC2,
they were given the option
to be able-- so you can see
they can see the instances here
still, and they should be
able to start the instance.
So we didn't give them the
authority to actually see
the status in the information.
So you see all these
reds that we're getting,
they're not allowed to describe.
Remember, we didn't give them
explicit describe access.
So even though they can
start and stop instances,
they can't describe.
But they should be
able to do this.
Let's go Ubuntu--
doesn't matter.
Try this again.
We might have actually forgot to
give them one extra permission
to select instance type.
So you can see here, they
technically have access.
They wouldn't get blocked
the same way of doing this.
And if we had started
another instance--
we actually might be able
to start one of these
that were already terminated.
Let me see.
Let's just click a random one.
And let's do instance state.
So yeah, you can see they were
able to start this instance.
And now it's throwing
into pending status.
And if we watch it now, we'll
see that in a little bit,
it will go green, probably.
We're still in pending.
Moral of the story
is, it does work.
So I'm not going to waste
too much time with you guys
on this one, but they should be
able to get that one launched
here in a little bit once it's
done out of the pending state.
So either way, moral of
the story is, it works.
That's really all I wanted
to go through, show you
how that process
works of creating--
of accessing users and all that.
And actually, I
can show you really
quick on my account, which
has access to create users,
what adding a user looks like.
So adding a user is pretty
straightforward as well too.
It's the same clicking
through windows.
Oh, you can actually
see there that it's
switched to the running state.
So let's stop that
one though because we
don't need it to run anymore.
So that one does have
the start stop instance.
So all good.
So we'll sign out of that
one now and close this out
and then go back full screen.
And so now if I go into
users and if I wanted
to add a new user in here,
I would just pop in here,
give a user name.
Let's call them user-4.
I would tell-- I would say
whether they have access keys,
so can they do
programmatic access?
Remember, we talked about
there's programmatic access
and management console access.
I have to explicitly
offer both of those.
If I don't, then they don't
have access to either of them.
But something's
required obviously.
So let's say we just
gave them that one.
Then I'd give them
either an auto generated
password, which is
what I gave you guys,
and then you have to change--
or I might've even done a custom
password, can't remember.
But either way, either auto
generate or custom password,
you provide it to the user.
And then here, you can tell them
to require a password at reset.
So with those accounts
that I showed you before,
I just said, no on that,
so I didn't have to do it.
But either way, then you
come into permissions,
then you can assign them
immediately to a user group.
You can copy permissions
from existing user
or attach existing
policies directly.
So remember I said,
there's a bunch
of premade policies from Amazon?
This is the list.
So you can see that is a long
list of all kinds of policies
you can add to them, OK?
And these are all just managed.
And then you can add tags
and all that good stuff too.
So that's really
the process there.
Again, nothing super fancy.
But hope that made some sense
and you got some experience now
and you know what
this looks like.
You may end up making a
user once or twice here
in this class.
But for the most part, you'll
just be using your own account.
So really, this is just
for your knowledge in case
you take the test or
you go on to a place
where you have-- you are
in charge of managing
these sort of resources, OK?
So leave the video there, and
I'll catch you guys next time.
Bye